are we losing an opportunity here I mean
could China effectively get ahead of us
because they're embracing this drone
technology in a way that we just aren't
right now I don't think we have enough
information yet to reach that conclusion
it's possible that Alibaba will face a
more favorable regulatory environment in
China I know Amazon has complained about
that recently said in a regulatory
filing that one of the problems with the
FAS reluctance to allow this kind of
drone delivery is that they'll have to
start experimenting elsewhere I think
the big takeaway from these experiments
at Alibaba is conducting three days
three Chinese cities they're delivering
tea it's like a previous conversation
about uber this and self-driving cars
this was a fantastic vision that
suddenly seems a lot more realistic than
it did just two years ago when Amazon
first started talking about you know
we've got some regulatory hurdles here
in the US when it comes to drones that
people don't like the idea is stuff
flying around in the sky that you're not
fully confident in and there's been a
lot of talk that we need to get a lot of
regulation in place before Amazon's ever
gonna be able to do anything like this
realistically I mean China here is doing
it now how long is it gonna take us do
you think Fred well look I mean China
this is an experiment along the lines of
the experiments that amazon and others
have run I know that there are
regulatory barriers in China there have
been companies who have been shut down
trying to make grown deliveries you know
I think everyone's gotta has work to do
to make this technology feasible to make
it safe particularly the big ups and the
landings in inclement weather which you
can imagine might be a little bit of a
problem and then gonna make sure there's
a market for it I mean what they're
betting here is that this is a faster
way to do expedient you know one-hour
delivery maybe cheaper you know people
love their Amazon Prime they love their
Next Day Delivery will they pay to have
something hurled through the air at into
their backyards there's a lot to be
worked out for now I'm not saying this
is a PR stunt but I think all these
companies enjoy showing showing off
their futuristic visions yeah and hey
look in a metropolitan area like New
York or San Francisco where you are
right all of these little drones
through the atmosphere especially not
crashing into each other anyway it's
exciting to talk about it an exciting
space